good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight
for centuries politicians in this
country assumed that in order to win an
election you had to convince voters to
vote for you you had to make their case
that was called democracy
but the defining strategic Insight of
the modern democratic party is they
don't really need to convince anyone of
anything what matters is demographics
you need to import enough people from
elsewhere people who are financially
dependent on you in order to live
that's the story of the State of
California that's why California changed
it's why Texas is changing but it's also
happening at the local level all over
the country Democrats have realized that
they win the vote in virtually every
major city
but the suburbs remain contested and
that matters because Suburban voters
like school boards and state legislators
and of course members of Congress so if
you want total control over the entire
country you need demographic change
everywhere including in the suburbs
this is a very obvious insight and
Democrats have been on the case for
quite a while back in 2009 the Obama
Administration took the county of
Westchester in New York a solidly
democratic place to court
why'd they do that well the
administration withheld tens of millions
of dollars in federal funding unless
Westchester pledged to build ten
thousand low-income high-density
apartments in their suburbs
the Obama Administration later
implemented a rule requiring suburbs to
take quote affirmative steps to
diversify their neighborhoods or else
they would lose Federal money
when he took office Joe Biden threw his
support behind something called the home
act among other things the home act
would allow the federal government to
withhold funds from local governments if
they didn't find ways to add high-rise
apartments or high density zoning to
suburbs
specifically the acts would have
prevented local governments from
enacting quote ordinances that ban
apartment buildings from certain
residential areas or set a minimum lot
size for a single family home
so you can't be safe in a leafy suburb
anymore it has to be urbanized the home
act has stalled in Congress it has never
become law but the bite Administration
didn't give up just because democracy
didn't produce the results they wanted
they still plan to change the suburbs
Forever by getting rid of them
Joe Biden's HUD secretary Marcia fudge a
former member of Congress explained last
year the administration was concerned
that African Americans could not afford
homes not because they're poor but
because home appraisers are racist watch
what the president has said is that we
have to look at everything through a
lens of equity and so what we have
realized is that people selling homes
just as the persons you were talking
about and even people buying homes if
their appraisal is not correct what we
find especially as black people in
communities of color and underserved
communities is we lose great wealth just
through the appraisal process
notice here the seizing of the moral
High Ground big picture if the bite
Administration cared about African
Americans they probably wouldn't
withdraw the police from America's
cities so they of course they don't care
but in point of fact former Congressman
Marcia fudge the clips you just saw
presented no evidence whatsoever that
there are white supremacist home
appraisers in this country or that they
are running amok if they exist who are
they
well she couldn't tell us but instead
she offered this anecdote
I live two doors from an all-white
Community I live in an all-black
community
my house is larger than the house two
doors for me my lot is larger than the
house two doors for me but my house is
valued at twenty five thousand dollars
less than the house two doors for me and
so once we can start to address and just
own up to the fact that we are
continuing to discriminate in Redline in
our housing efforts then I think that we
can make sure that we can start to deal
with the racial wealth yeah
yeah so as the left is often telling you
an anecdote is not a study noticing
something around you doesn't make it
universally true you've proved nothing
you've really told us a little story
Marsha fudge's lived experience tells
her that there is racism in home
appraisals but there's still no data on
that there's no evidence whatsoever it
is at this point completely made up
but Kamala Harris is convinced
completely here she was last year
the home appraisal Workforce is one of
the least diverse in our nation
less than five percent of Home
appraisers in America
are people of color
this lack of diversity can introduce
both conscious and unconscious biases
that make home appraisals less accurate
and less Fair
our Administration will now require
those who conduct appraisals for federal
programs must take part in anti-bias
Fair Housing and fair lending training
there are solutions there are solutions
we're just going to brainwash the home
appraisers we're going to put them in
bias training really if you wanted more
black home appraisers why wouldn't you
start a program to train them no the
only job training program this
Administration has gotten behind in two
and a half years is getting black people
to sell more weed in the cities
literally we're legalizing weed we're
going to make sure the weed dispensaries
have African-American owners they're not
training any black people to be home
appraisers
and by the way the premise of this is
itself unproven that home appraisers are
racist why do we think that again
there's zero evidence of that it's a
slur upon home appraisers by the way why
do they deserve this abuse well they
don't
they're not hurting anyone they're
accounting types why is the
administration calling them racist
but they are and they have been for more
than a year
so once again they're using fake
allegations of racism as a pretext for a
political plan and in this case the plan
is to flood the suburbs with voters they
believe will support the Democratic
party it's super simple they don't
deserve the moral High ground it's
because they're throwing race around or
claiming they speak on behalf of black
people Kamala Harris is claiming to
speak on behalf of black people right
okay that doesn't mean that they're
right
but no one's stopping them so without
any vote in Congress the bite
Administration has just introduced a
rule not a law a rule that will punish
Americans who've tried to do the right
thing punish people with high credit
scores the people with high credit
scores will pay higher fees on their
mortgage payments to subsidize people
who haven't maintained good credit
so these rules take effect on May 1st
whether you like it or not and they mean
that anyone with good credit that's
defined as a score of 680 or above is
going to have to pay roughly 40 a month
extra on their mortgage fees than those
with lower scores on home loans around
400 Grand so here's an example if you
have a FICO score of 620 you get a 1.75
percent discount on your mortgage fees
if you have a 740 score in other words
you pay your bills on time you've done
the right thing you're a good citizen
you have to pay one percent more
so you don't get a discount for doing
the right thing and paying your bills
you get punished we are incentivizing
bad behavior we're hurting the good
people since the day you were born you
have been told pay your debts it's not
your money you borrowed it from somebody
else you have to pay it back if you
don't it's stealing
now we're saying if you don't steal
we're going to hurt you
and in real life that means that over
the course of a 30-year mortgage for a
400 000 home that's a swing of more than
fourteen thousand dollars and they're
claiming racism to justify this
black Americans are the only racial
group in this country with average
credit scores of under 680. now why is
that
we don't know
white Hispanics Asians have higher
credit scores therefore as you'd expect
the mortgage dial rate for
African-American Borrowers is higher
than the overall populations double
in this country's biggest markets and
that's the reason the suburbs have
different demographics from the cities
that's called economics now if you
wanted to change that you would
encourage people
to have good spending habits and pay
back their debt but they don't care
about that making people happier getting
them out of debt no they want to change
the suburbs make them denser so they'll
be more reliably Democratic voting
that's the bottom line it's always about
election results it's always about power
it's not improving anybody's life
meanwhile the Democratic party's donors
in private Equity of course are happy
it'll be even harder for Americans with
good credit to buy homes why
because that will mean more renters
Renters of homes they own
home ownership is increasingly Out Of
Reach in our portfolio the majority
cannot buy home cannot afford to buy
home or don't have the credit to buy the
homes I think if you asked a lot of
Millennials and that tends to be our
primary resident they would probably
tell you that they don't necessarily
desire to own a home or to own a car
they've grown up in the sharing economy
and for what's important to them is
lifestyle right and so if they can move
into this what we call a turnkey or
hotel ready home and have a low
maintenance lifestyle that's very
compelling for them
people don't want to even they don't
want to own anything they want to be
penniless and impoverished live at the
whims of oligarchs that's really what
they want do you own anything Mr
oligarch guy
she never asked subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight